Lulu American despot
sis I'm currently did
of the ICT P East African Institute for
fundamental research here
we focus mainly on high energy physics
condensed matter physics and solid earth
geophysics but at the same time they
problem we choose in these areas are
problems that we believe will impact
Africa a lot for instance in condensed
matter physics we try to work on
problems related to energy and problems
related to water which are problems that
are important in Africa
this is what I focus on
defied models I give the energies of
systems these simplified models can now
be used to predict the properties of
catalysts or the properties of different
materials that are useful in society
for instance they can be used to predict
the properties of what is called quantum
dots this contemn does are useful in
solar cells they can also be used to
predict the properties of
superconductors they can be used to
describe how a chemical reaction will
occur once you know the energy from this
simplified energy model
within the next day years in theoretical
physics in Africa there will be a lot of
researchers all over the 52 countries of
Africa doing research at the cutting
edge we want people to be doing research
at the cutting edge of high energy
physics in string theory in cosmology
and other important areas in high energy
physics I want people to be doing
research at the cutting edge in
superconductors in development of
catalysts in development of
understanding of chemical reactions so
all of Africa I want people to be there
at the cutting edge developing new
technology based on fundamental science